rappers are targets like you can't even
you can't even make music dangerous
that's the most dangerous job in the
world yeah i feel like
you got to go to clubs you got to
like you're dropping your location off
from the be there
artist and then you know people
they just think rappers be
and they
they think i don't know i feel like
people just feel like rappers like
you know they don't deserve all that
sometimes well that is true right if you
if you really think about it if you have
enemies you openly advertise where
you're going to be often yeah
artists are an easy target for
any sort of like agency who wants to
just pick on somebody you know what i'm
saying and yeah on both sides of the
coin i just feel like it's like it's
like a tough position to be in at times
that people don't realize do you ever
feel stressed out like what's because
unravel yeah man i mean [__] you
obviously got some like pretty public
beefs that have what happened and i'm
not not he's not even about that though
i don't think i'll be stressed because
like
a lot of fake stuff
be going on